for more information on tutoring
personalized video solutions or how to
support move university and the
production of more videos check out Mufi
university comm thank you and enjoy so
next up is electronegativity so as far
as the definition goes electronegativity
is the relative ability or tendency of
an atom to withdraw or pull electrons or
electron density towards itself across a
chemical bond so if two atoms are bound
together and one is more electronegative
than the other view more electronegative
atom will pull electrons or the electron
density towards itself okay so what's
the trend on the periodic table okay
well let your negativity of an of an
atom or an element increases up and to
the right okay and this excludes the
noble gases because they really don't
well actually have a question here why
don't we consider the electronegativity
of the noble gases and the reason why is
because they they don't really form
compounds I've seen xenon form compounds
but it doesn't form very many the point
is that especially the smaller ones like
helium and neon they don't really form
compounds or argon I've never seen them
for compounds so they're not gonna bond
to another atom right so if they can't
bond to another atom they have no
relative ability to withdraw pull
electrons towards themselves right but
so the question though is why is it that
that ability increases up and to the
right on the periodic table right why is
that just reveal this right just we have
a visual right and of course
we're excluding the noble gases right
but yeah why is that well let's think
about atomic size right
the smaller an atom is the closer its
nucleus is to the electrons in the
chemical bond and the more able the
positively charged nucleus is to attract
those electrons in that bond okay so
let's think about this example here
between HF right hydrofluoric acid and
HCl hydrochloric acid here I've shown
I've drawn the lewis structures for
hydrofluoric acid and for hydrochloric
acid if you don't know what that really
is this is just a depiction of the
hydrogen atom in the fluorine atom bound
here so there are electrons in this
little line here and same idea over here
in fact obviously that there and same
idea here there are electrons in this
little line right a pair of electrons
and so well what we're gonna basically
think about between HF and HCl is their
size differences so HF is is shown here
by this little green the green circle
right or the green sphere should be a
sphere but it's in 2d and with the HCl
that's gonna be a little bit bigger
right it's right below it I've
exaggerated the difference inside it's
not drawn to scale or anything but
what's key to think about is that there
are electrons between these two atoms
okay there are electrons right here
these electrons that I just mentioned
right in that bond they're the same same
ones right there okay they're in between
the two spheres okay the same idea over
here actually right there are electrons
in there okay and so these nuclei are
going to pull on the electrons that
between the two atoms right and so are
these these guys are going to pull on
the electron density between them okay
now how close the nucleus is positive
charge is to those electrons is pretty
important because the electrostatic
force is inversely related to the
distance between the two charges so if
the two charges are closer the
electrostatic force is greater okay so
what we will your reveal here if we look
at the radius the radius of fluorine is
is small compared to the radius of
chlorine which is a little bit bigger
right so what happens is that fluorines
positively charged nucleus is closer to
the electrons in the chemical bond
between it and hydrogen right so it can
pull them across the bond towards itself
more than chlorine can okay and that has
a lot to do with its its size now both
of them are pretty electronegative atoms
though if we think about the idea that
they're the reason they're apart part of
the reason they're also pulling electron
density towards themselves is because
they they kind of want to reach
something like a noble gas configuration
ish kind of thing so that they pull an
electron density that electron density
towards themselves then they feel like
they have extra electrons so they're
closer to that ideal stable conformation
or configuration rather okay now there's
always the question of what's the most
electronegative element and that is
fluorine okay that's something worth
knowing and electronegativity is a
relative ability to withdraw or pull
electron density towards itself fluorine
is the best at doing that so fluorine is
a is in a bond with anything else it's
going to pull the electrons towards it
more than the other atom it's bound to
is so and there's actually a scale like
fluorines electronegativity is 4.0 and
everything is is relative to this 4.0
the second most is oxygen it's a close
second with 3.5 I believe
okay now what's the least
electronegative atom or you can think
about it as the most electropositive
atom although that term is used much
less frequently it's gonna be the
biggest element right the biggest atom
and that'll be francium although I read
some people say that because francium is
is really really rare it's often just
taken to be cesium because cesium is
more more prevalent but I'm gonna go
with francium here okay okay cool
but now hang on a second wait a minute
didn't we say that electron affinity
described how attracted an atom was two
electrons how is that different from
what we just talked about here in
electronegativity well to answer that
question and how to clear up the
difference is in a little comparison
check out the next video anyway I hope
that video was helpful thank you for
watching if you found that video helpful
don't forget to like comment subscribe
and share with friends
thank you and happy studying